[Musik]
herzlich willkommen bei ZDF heute live
schön dass ihr dabei seid wir sprechen
hier heute über China und vor allem über
den künftigen deutschen Umgang mit der
erfolgsrepublik heute morgen hat die
Bundesregierung nämlich zum ersten Mal
eine china-strategie festgelegt und
präsentiert und dieser künftig als
Orientierung dienen wie hier in
Deutschland politisch aber auch
wirtschaftlich mit dem Land umgegangen
werden sollen denn gerade zeigt sich das
Geschäft mit China ist ein ziemlich
teures Risiko was genau steht aber in
diesem Strategiepapier drin das hat sich
mein Kollege Andreas angeguckt
wenn es nach der Außenministerin
gegangen wäre wäre Deutschlands erste
china-strategie deutlich schneller
erschienen und deutlich härter
ausgefallen bärburg ist die Ministerin
die China am kritischsten sieht
repressiva nach innen offensiver nach
außen
china hat sich verändert und deswegen
muss ich auch unsere China-Politik
verändern während die chinesische
Führung Deutschland als nichts anderes
als einen Partner bezeichnet nennt die
china-strategie das aufstrebende
Riesenreich Partner Wettbewerber und
systemischer Rivale mit Sorge sieht die
Bundesregierung wie abhängig die
deutsche Industrie vom chinesischen
Markt aber auch von chinesischen
Importen ist
98% aller Seltenen Erden bezieht die EU
aus China 97% bestimmter Antibiotika und
83% des Elements Mangan mit vorerst nur
sanftem Druck und später vielleicht
stärkerem will die Regierung die
Wirtschaft zum Umsteuern bewegen wir
stellen Deutschland breiter auf
diversifizieren unsere leberkästen und
die Versorgung mit wichtigen Rohstoffen
sie kennen dabei unsere Devise die
risking und nicht die katling Risiken ab
mindern aber nicht abkoppeln promt lässt
China den deutschen Einsatz kritisieren
zwanghaftes die risking auf der
Grundlage von ideologischen Vorurteilen
und wettbewerbsangst ist nur
kontraproduktiv und verschärft die
Risiken künstlich
Deutschland sucht ein Auskommen mit
China ohne seine Werte und seinen
Wohlstand zu verlieren
ja und wie Peking auf dieses
Strategiepapier blickt das will ich
jetzt von meiner zdf-kollegin und
Korrespondentin Miriam Steimer wissen
die und jetzt live aus Peking
zugeschaltet ist hallo Miriam
hallo
Miriam ich glaube es ist schon ziemlich
spät bei dir vielleicht hast du trotzdem
mal erste Reaktionen aus Peking auf
dieses deutsche Strategiepapier für uns
und der Wiederhall aus China heute der
war ziemlich leise und das liegt
einerseits an der Zeitverschiebung die
du gerade schon ansprichst also wir sind
euch ja hier sechs Stunden voraus das
heißt als das Strategiepapier in
Deutschland um die Mittagszeit
vorgestellt wurde war hier schon früher
Abend es gibt ein paar kleinere
Reaktionen die global times zur
Sprachrohr der Kommunistischen Partei
hat sich einen Punkt rausgepickt und
berichtet dass Deutschlands Ziel mit
China nicht die kapling sei das trifft
jetzt nicht unbedingt den Kern des
Papiers aber das ist natürlich ein Satz
den auch die Parteiführung hier in China
gerne unterschreibt wir haben gerade im
Beitrag schon gehört es gab noch eine
Reaktion und zwar von der chinesischen
Botschaft in Berlin diese ja die
Anmerkung dass dieses zwanghafte die
richtigen eigentlich die Risiken noch
erhöhe war ein Zitat das schwingt immer
auch so ein bisschen der Vorwurf mit äh
dieses Konzept Risiko Minimierung sei
von den USA aufgezwungen das ist ja oft
gebrauchtes
mit gebrauchte Propaganda Erklärungen
das stammt also gar nicht würde gar
nicht von Deutschland stammen sondern
käme vom Feind vom Feindbild Chinas von
den USA außerdem hieß es von der
Botschaft die in dieser Strategie Papier
zeige das ist das Deutschland vor vielen
Problemen stehe und die seien nicht von
China verursacht und wenn es um die
Bewältigung von solchen
Herausforderungen ginge dann sei ich
China eher Partner und nicht Rivale es
gibt noch einen zweiten Grund warum der
Widerhall hier heute ziemlich leise war
das liegt nicht nur an der
Zeitverschiebung sondern ich gehe davon
aus dass auch morgen in den staatlich
kontrollierten Medien nicht sehr viel
über diese Strategie Papier berichtet
werden wird warum das liegt daran dass
damit ein Bild vermittelt wird das die
Staats- und Parteiführung nicht
unbedingt vermitteln möchte das wird
vielleicht besonders deutlich wenn ich
man anderes Beispiel gebe von ein paar
Wochen waren die
Regierungskonsultationen in Berlin und
darüber wurde hier extrem ausführlich
berichtet auch in den
hauptnachrichtensendung minutenlang
sah man die schönen Bilder aus Berlin
die vielen Minister die dort zu Besuch
waren die Partnerschaft die Freundschaft
die dort gefeiert wurde das ist ein Bild
ähm das hier sehr gerne berichtet wird
damit kann man zeigen das läuft ganz gut
auf der internationalen Ebene und vor
allem auch ein Gegenpunkten im
Gegengewicht setzen zum Konflikt mit den
USA
ja ihr merkt Miriam beobachtet dieses
Thema natürlich für uns permanent wenn
ihr Fragen an sie habt dann schickt sie
gerne hier in den Youtube Chat oder per
Mail an die eingeblendete Adresse du
sagst gerade der Widerhall heute aus
Peking verhältnismäßig leise auf die
deutsche neue wirtschaftliche Strategie
im Umgang mit China was ist denn
eigentlich Chinas wirtschaftliche
Strategie welche Ziele und Wege
verfolgen die
ja da gibt es eine interessante Sache
seit 2020 verfolgt Peking das sogenannte
Konzept der zwei Kreisläufe Kreisläufe
dahinter verbirgt sich einerseits den
Binnenkonsum anzuheizen und andererseits
die Exportabhängigkeit zu reduzieren und
das kommt jetzt wahrscheinlich bekannt
vor China hat das Konzept ausgegeben als
Reaktion auf den Handelskonflikt mit den
USA es geht dabei darum dass die sich
nicht mehr so sehr zu fokussieren auf
die Weltwirtschaft die sich um die USA
kreist sondern den Binnenkonsum im
eigenen Land zu stärken und stärkere
stärkeren Handel mit regionalen
Bündnissen ähm zu treiben wie zum
Beispiel Asien oder Europa Chinas
Wirtschaft das ist glaube ich der der
wichtige Punkt das ist so ein bisschen
das Sorgenkind im Moment und das ist
auch der Grund warum auch die Pekinger
Staatsführung sehr genau auf dieses
Papier schauen wird und sich diese über
60 Seiten sehr genau anschauen wird es
gab ja die große Hoffnung nach dem
plötzlichen Ende der extrem
corona-maßnahmen hier im Land dass die
Wirtschaft die chinesische Wirtschaft
sich davon schnell erholen wird und das
läuft sehr viel schleppender als
erwartet gerade heute gab es zum
Beispiel neue Exportzahlen also die
Zahlen für den Juni und die werden ja
immer verglichen mit den mit dem Juni
Zahlen von vor einem Jahr und das Minus
von diesem juni zum letzten Juni ist so
groß wie seit drei Jahren nicht ist noch
mal so ein Indiz dafür es geht der
chinesischen Wirtschaft nicht gut und
das ist auch ein ganz wichtiger Grund in
dieser Debatte um das Strategiepapier
heute aus Deutschland denn China braucht
Deutschland China braucht die EU China
braucht diesen Absatzmarkt denn daran
hängen auch viele Arbeitsplätze hier in
China
ja und über diese Wechselwirkung über
gegenseitige ab gegenseitige
Abhängigkeiten spreche ich auch gleich
noch mal mit China-Experte Bernhard Bart
von Merkator Institut für China ist also
wenn ihr für den Fragen habt dann
schreibt sie gerne in stock Miriam
kannst du uns mal zusammenfassen was ich
an den Beziehungen zwischen China und
Deutschland generell in der letzten Zeit
verändert hat also wie kam es jetzt auch
zu diesem Strategiepapier
ja ich glaube da gibt es zwei große
Punkte das eine ist das Ende der Ära
Merkel und das zweite ist Russlands
Angriffskrieg in der Ukraine
wenn wir mit Merkel anfangen wenn ich
mit meinem Kamerateam in China unterwegs
bin oft auch in sehr abgelegenen
Regionen wo Leute vielleicht zum ersten
Mal sogar Ausländer sehen dann sind die
immer sehr neugierig und kommen und
Fragen wo kommt ihr her und wenn wir
dann erzählen wir kommen aus Deutschland
dann sind es zwei Sachen die uns ganz
häufig begegnen das erste ist die kennen
irgendwelche deutschen bekannten
Fußballspieler und das zweite ist Merkel
Merkel und gute Beziehungen das ist so
ein Image dass ich total festgesetzt hat
in China das ist auch immer noch gibt
also diese 16 Jahre Kontinuität die
vielen Treffen der viele persönliche
Kontakt das war natürlich der
Verlässlichkeit was China sehr geschätzt
hat und vor allem die Priorität auf
guten Geschäften für beide Seiten das
ist natürlich was was ich nun total
geändert hat und der zweite Punkt ähm
Russlands Angriffskrieg in der Ukraine
die die für China und wenn wir ehrlich
sind für uns alle ein bisschen sehr
überraschende Geschlossenheit des
Westens darauf hin für China dieser
schwierige Spagat weiter fest an
Russland Seite zu stehen und auf der
anderen Seite aber nicht so weit zu
gehen um den Westen auch nicht so zu
sehr zu vergraulen um irgendwie die
Wirtschaftsbeziehungen doch noch
aufrechterhalten zu können und natürlich
was das in Deutschland extrem geändert
hat dieses sich bewusst machen von
Risiken und dieses abklopfen auf wo gibt
es denn eigentlich sonst noch
Abhängigkeiten um die wir uns mal
kümmern sollten
ja also auch hier eigentlich ähnlich wie
in der Russland Politik eine ein zu
großes Vertrauen in der ihrer Merkel und
jetzt können sich diese Beziehung
aufgrund der aktuellen geopolitischen
Lage ab kannst du und sagen was müsste
jetzt aktuell noch passieren oder was
könnte potentiell passieren damit die
geopolitische Lage sich zwischen China
und dem Westen zwischen China und
Deutschland noch mehr anspannt
Veränderung des Status quo sei nur
möglich auf friedliche Weise und im
gegenseitigen Einverständnis die Lage
von Taiwan die wichtigen Handelsstraßen
rundherum die Bedeutung von Taiwan z.B
für die chip-industrie die bedeutet
natürlich dass das die ganze Welt
treffen wird wenn es dort ein Konflikt
gibt dann ist das was nicht nur für
Deutschland große Auswirkungen haben
wird sondern für die ganze Welt
ja und auf diese Abhängigkeiten der Chip
Industrie und auch die Wichtigkeit
dieser Handelsrouten gehen wir gleich
noch mal ein Mülheim ich habe noch eine
Frage aus der Community an dich und zwar
fragte jemand auf Youtube was sagt denn
die chinesische Seite zu geplanten neuen
bricks Währung welche Auswirkungen hätte
die neue Währung auf den Euro kannst du
uns dazu schon was einschätzen
oh Gott nee das kann ich gerade nicht in
der in der Kürze da muss ich leider
passen
das ist kein Problem das werden wir
sicher an anderer Stelle noch mal
vertiefen vielen dank dir dass du für
uns wach geblieben bist ich wünsche dir
alles Gute und sag gute Nacht noch
Peking
sehr gerne
ja und äh um zu verstehen welche Folgen
dieses politische Umdenken im Umgang mit
China hat müssen wir uns noch mal vor
Augen führen wie abhängig die deutsche
Wirtschaft aktuell eigentlich von der
Volksrepublik ist und das hat sich mein
Kollege Carsten heckes für uns
angeschaut
der Hamburger Hafen knapp die Hälfte
aller Container hier kommt aus China
oder hat die Volksrepublik als Ziel
allein im Mai wurden Waren im Wert von
ca 13,3 Milliarden Euro aus dem Reich
der Mitte importiert
ununterbrochen seit 2016 ist China
Deutschlands wichtigster Handelspartner
besonders was den Import angeht hier
zeigt sich das Deutschland in den
letzten Jahren immer stärker auf made in
China setzt 2022 waren die
importausgaben nach China fast so hoch
wie die Ausgaben bei den zweiten
Drittplatzierten den USA und den
Niederlanden zusammen
das liegt unter anderem daran dass die
Volksrepublik einen nahezu Monopol auf
seltene Erden hat kaum ein modernes
Produkt kommt ohne sie aus einen
Großteil des deutschen Bedarfes China
auch der chinesische Markt hat für viele
Firmen eine große Bedeutung der
VW-Konzern etwa verkaufte letztes Jahr
mehr als ein Drittel seiner Autos in
China auch der DAX-Konzern Infineon
macht etwa ein Viertel seines Umsatzes
dort der Chemie-Konzern BASF plant
Milliarden schwere Investitionen in sein
China Geschäft möchte so ein fehlendes
Wachstum in Europa ausgleichen die
Abhängigkeit von China ist groß die
deutsche Wirtschaft ist auf gute
Beziehungen zu Peking angewiesen
ja und über diese Abhängigkeiten und die
Herausforderungen und vielleicht auch
die Folgen für meinen und vielleicht
auch euren Geldbeutel spreche ich jetzt
mit Bernhard Barth von Mercator Institut
für China und schon zugeschaltet ist
hallo Herr Barth
hallo guten Abend
lasst uns noch mal zurückspringen an den
Anfang dieses Streams da haben wir uns
ja angeguckt was in der Strategie die da
heute morgen veröffentlicht wurde drin
steht und das große Stichwort für
deutsche Unternehmen für unsere deutsche
Wirtschaft lautet laut der
Bundesregierung die risking so nennt man
das Bemühen einseitige wirtschaftliche
Abhängigkeiten von China abzubauen was
glauben Sie denn sie inwiefern wird die
deutsche Wirtschaft darauf eingehen bzw
inwiefern tut sie das vielleicht auch
schon
das Problem der Abhängigkeiten ist den
Unternehmen in den letzten Jahren sehr
bewusst geworden
insbesondere auch wie politischer Druck
benutzt werden kann um diese
Abhängigkeiten eben gegen Unternehmen
und auch gegen Regierungen dann
auszuspielen der Ukraine Krieg was das
mit unseren Gaslieferungen und
Gaspreisen gemacht hat ist dafür das
Beispiel dass jeden der das nicht sehen
wollte davon überzeugt hat dass das eine
reale Gefahr ist unsere Verpflichtung
mit China ist natürlich viel tiefer und
viel vielschichtiger als die mit
Russland und deswegen ist da ein großes
Bewusstsein dass die Abhängigkeiten wenn
die Bestehen mit einem Land das
politisch so aufgestellt ist wie China
das ist und das völlig zu Recht als
systemischer Rivale
bezeichnet wird und das wird in dieser
Strategie sehr deutlich gemacht dass
dieser Aspekt der systemischen Rivalität
in den letzten Jahren zugenommen hat
dass wenn man da Abhängigkeiten hat man
sehr gut beraten ist sich die genau
anzuschauen und wo man irgendwie kann zu
vermindern
sie sagen viele deutsche Unternehmen die
meisten deutschen Unternehmen haben das
spätestens seitdem Ukraine Krieg oder
seit dem Ausbruch des Ukraine Kriegs auf
dem Schirm das ist schlecht ist diese
Riesen Abhängigkeiten zu haben die muss
ich mir das denn vorstellen was muss
denn jetzt ein Unternehmen ganz konkret
für Schritte gehen um zu dir richten
es gibt unterschiedliche Fälle sie haben
die
Automobilindustrie gerade angesprochen
wenn große deutsche Automobilhersteller
die natürlich für unseren Arbeitsmarkt
wahnsinnig wichtig sind ein ganz großen
Teil ihres Geschäfts in China machen und
Angst haben müssen dass der
wegbrechen könnte oder wie es jetzt
schon passiert stark abnimmt dann muss
man dann natürlich schauen wie man
unabhängiger von dem Markt wird immer
neue Märkte erschließt oder wie man sich
auch eingesteht das eine bestimmte
Wachstumsphase die man dort hatte
vielleicht zu Ende geht und dass man
sich davon unabhängig machen muss es
gibt die armen Abhängigkeiten in die
andere Richtung wo wir Produkte aus
China beziehen wir haben das in der
Pandemie bemerkt wie wir abhängig sind
von chinesischen Masken das betrifft
aber auch
Zulieferprodukte für die
Arzneimittelindustrie z.B für
Antibiotika oder das betrifft die
angesprochenen Seltenen Erden wenn wir
die überwiegend aus China beziehen dann
müssen wir zusehen dass wir andere
Quellen dafür haben das ist teuer aber
viel teurer ist es das nicht zu tun
trotzdem müssen sich Unternehmen jetzt
umschauen und sie sagen gerade dann ist
es vielleicht auch für eine Zeit mal
vorbei mit dem Wachstum was bedeutet das
denn ganz konkret jetzt für Sie und auch
für mich als Konsument in was bedeutet
das für unseren Geldbeutel
auf der einen Seite bedeutet wenn dort
das Wachstum vorbei ist das natürlich
bestimmte Exporte die wir nach China in
der Vergangenheit hatten eher
zurückgehen es ist sehr sehr schwer zu
bemessen wie viele Jobs in Deutschland
wirklich an China hängen es ist klar
dass das eher abnimmt bei den Produkten
die wir aus China beziehen und wo wir
sehen dass wir uns alternative Quellen
dafür beschaffen müssen da wird einfach
dadurch dass man dann neue Quellen
braucht das teuren das konkrete Beispiel
der seltenen Erden noch mal zu nehmen es
wurde gerade gesagt da hat China ein
fast Monopol darauf das sieht nicht
daran dass man nur in China die abbauen
könnte es geht darum dass der Prozess um
die brauchbar zu machen ungeheuer Umwelt
belastend ist sehr aufwendig ist das ist
etwas was wir bei uns hier überhaupt
nicht in der Form bisher tun wir waren
froh dass China das sehr billig gemacht
hat und die Umweltbelastungen kaufte
das kann man auch mit guten
Umweltstandards machen aber das ist
teuer man könnte die auch recyceln aus
Produkten so wie wir es jetzt gerade
auch bei den von China mit Restriktionen
belegten
mitteilen Gallium und Germanium sehen
aber all das kostet also die risking ist
keine billige Strategie und wir müssen
uns klar machen dass die geopolitische
Situation in der wir sind das ist da
kein kostenlosen Ausweg gibt
sie haben gerade schon angesprochen
dieses Gallium und Germanium da ist ja
folgendes passiert hier hatte Anfang
Juli den Export von die von für die
Chip-Produktion wichtigen Rohstoffen
erschwert das sind die Stoffe die sie
ansprechen nachdem aber die USA den
Export von hochleistungs-chips an China
beschränkt hatte also da reagiert man
gerade sehr stark offeneinander
inwiefern könnten wir denn hier in
Deutschland Teil eines solches ja
handelskrieges werden
wir sind da mittendrin worum es jetzt
konkret ging war nicht nur dass die USA
chip-lieferungen in nach China
beschränkt haben sondern dass sie auch
verlangt haben dass europäische
Unternehmen die eine wichtige Position
in der Lieferkette von chip-fabriken
haben dass die auch nicht nach China
ihre neuesten Technologien liefern ganz
konkret geht es um das niederländische
Unternehmen ASML das aber viel bezieht
von deutschen Unternehmen von Zeiss von
Trumpf die dürfen ihre modernsten
Maschinen nicht mehr nach China
exportieren und darauf reagiert China
das sind solche Konflikte die wir in der
Zukunft häufiger sehen werden und
unabhängig davon was in jedem Einzelfall
dahinter steht hier eben der Anspruch
oder der der Versuch China bei wichtigen
Zukunftstechnologien nicht zu schnell
aufholen zu lassen
das hat in jedem Fall für uns den Effekt
dass es uns einfach was kostet
ja eine weitere Herausforderung sind ja
das haben Sie auch schon angesprochen
eben diese neuen Märkte Sie sich jetzt
die deutsche Wirtschaft sucht auf die
aber natürlich auch die chinesische
Wirtschaft will und warum China da ein
entsprechenden Vorteil hat das hat mein
Kollege mal zusammengefasst hier ist ein
Stück zu neuen Seidenstraße
die one Belt one Road Initiative Welt
für die verschiedenen Handelsrouten über
Land von China via Zentralasien über den
Nahen Osten bis nach Europa
[Musik]
bezeichnet den Seeweg der von China aus
über Südostasien Südasien Afrika sowie
schließlich durch den Suezkanal bis in
die Adria verläuft Seitenwege führen bis
Südamerika und in die Arktis
auf der Strecke liegen 65 Länder knapp
zwei Drittel der Weltbevölkerung sind
direkt oder indirekt betroffen hier
werden mehr als 2500
Infrastrukturprojekte angeschoben neue
Gleisstrecken Straßen Brücken oder Häfen
aber auch Öl und Gas werden ausgebaut
ja wie ihr gesehen habt dieses Stück war
von meiner Kollegin Petra Riffe können
Sie uns erläutern was hat diese neue
Seidenstraße die an über 60 Ländern
vorbeiführt für Vorteile für China
diese sogenannte neue Seidenstraße ist
letztlich ein Sammelbegriff für Chinas
aus dem Wirtschaftspolitik China braucht
eben genauso wie wir
diversere Exportmärkte es will ohnehin
seinen internationalen Beziehungen
Bereiter aufstellen China würde gerne
sich als Führungsmacht der
Schwellenländer oder wie man das jetzt
immer nennt des globalen Südens
etablieren und darum versucht es
in allen Bereichen seine Beziehungen zu
anderen Ländern zu vertiefen dadurch
dass es dorthin exportiert das ist
Infrastrukturprojekte dort macht das ist
politische Beziehungen pflegt und das
lief in den vergangenen Jahren dieses
Jahr ist da das zehnjährige Jubiläum
unter diesem Dach der neuen Seidenstraße
tatsächlich differenziert sich das
inzwischen aus es ist klar das ist da
auch um Sicherheitsinteressen geht und
China hat eine globale
Sicherheitsinitiative
es geht
auch um Entwicklungsfragen das sind
alles aber auch macht politische Fragen
mit den China ein großen Teil der Welt
als alliierte für sich gewinnen möchte
Teams gerade zu Anfang noch mal gesagt
Deutschland sucht sich neue Märkte will
diversifizieren China versucht das auch
heißt das Deutschland und China
konkurrieren dann letztendlich um die
selben Märkte
oh ja genau das heißt das und das macht
die china-strategie tatsächlich auch
sehr deutlich dass wir diesen Wettbewerb
annehmen müssen und das wäre da
vielleicht in der Vergangenheit auch ein
bisschen naiv waren
zu erwarten dass unsere Produkte da
immer im Vorteil sind china macht diesen
Ländern schon sehr gute Angebote um mal
konkret zu machen China kann inzwischen
auch sehr gute zu strecken bauen und tut
das relativ einfach China bringt dafür
Finanzierung mit China bringt die
eigenen Arbeitskräfte mit um diese
Zugstrecken sollen China betreibt die
zum Teil sogar China kann sehr schnell
und recht einfach Ländern zu strecken
hinstellen und das gleiche gilt für
Kraftwerke und Telekommunikationsnetze
das alles ist aber natürlich auch nach
einem ganz anderen System gestrickt als
bei uns das schafft Abhängigkeiten dass
die Chinesen das bauen heißt eben da
werden keine lokalen Jobs für geschaffen
das China das
und betreibt sorgt dafür dass China da
auch sehr viel Macht hat dass China da
seine Technologie
hinschickt bedeutet dass das auch nicht
technologieoffen für andere Technologien
hinterher ist das sind
abhängigkeitsfallen die China ganz
bewusst baut aber die Abhängigkeit
fallen sind natürlich etwas was erst oft
viel später kommt und das ist etwas
worauf ihr einfach bessere Antworten
brauchen und um der Fairness Willen
nicht immer geht es da nur um
Abhängigkeit fallen und nicht immer sind
die Länder die sowas in Anspruch nehmen
da ihrerseits naiv und lassen sich da
über den Tisch ziehen aber oft müssen
sie auch schauen was können sie sich
leisten und sie vergleichen einfach
global wer macht ihnen für ihre
Entwicklung die besseren Angebote und
das sind oft die Chinesen und da müssen
wir besser werden selber auch Angebote
zu haben das läuft in Europa unter dem
Mantel global Gateway das heißt wir
haben uns in Zukunft in Deutschland
vielleicht zu sehr auf deutsche Produkte
verlassen und auf ihre
Alleinstellungsmerkmal die ist das denn
politisch was glauben Sie inwiefern hat
die deutsche Politik auch diese
Bedrohung Chinas diese strategische
wirtschaftliche geopolitische Rolle
Chinas unterschätzt
ihre Kolleginnen in Peking hat es gerade
schon angesprochen die
Ära Merkel hat in der zweiten Hälfte von
Angela Merkels Amtszeit immer noch ein
China Bild hoch gehalten dass so nicht
mehr der Realität entsprach diese
Abhängigkeiten die entstanden sind und
die China sehr bewusst aufgebaut hat die
hat die deutsche Politik lange nicht
gesehen da war an andere Länder zum
Beispiel Australien oder auch Chinas
Nachbarn Japan Korea die viel engere
Verpflichtung haben aber sich auch der
politischen Risiken viel unmittelbarer
bewusst sind die Waren das schneller
aber wir sind jetzt auch dabei diese
China Strategie ist wirklich von der
Sprache von der Tonalität durchdrungen
davon dass die Botschaft wirklich
angekommen ist dass wir hier
große Risiken haben die wir uns sehr
ernsthaft anschauen müssen und die wir
abbauen müssen weil eben das sonst
enorme Kosten für uns hat
ein finanziell aber auch für die Zukunft
für unsere Wettbewerbsfähigkeit für
letztlich wenn es ganz groß machen will
den Wohlstand in Europa das hier eine
wirklich große Herausforderung
die sagen sprachlich ist die Botschaft
auf jeden Fall angekommen in dieser
neuen Strategie trotzdem besitzt ja zum
Beispiel Chinas staatskonten Costco
Anteile am Hamburger Hafen wir
diskutieren auch gerade darüber ob die
sich chinesischen Komponenten in
deutschen
5g-mobilfunknetzen in Ordnung sind bzw
inwieweit sie problematisch sind wie
riskant ist es denn dass wir Teile
unserer Infrastruktur in chinesische
Hände geben
ich finde das sehr problematisch und der
der Einstieg von costgo in Hamburg ist
ja auch sehr umstritten gewesen und
letztlich war das eine politische
Entscheidung dass wir genehmigen die
entscheidenden Ministerien sowohl das
Wirtschaftsministerium als auch das
Außenministerium waren gegen diese
Investition das Kanzleramt konkret oder
stolz als ehemaliger Hamburger
Bürgermeister hat das dann doch
bewilligt und es geht da gar nicht immer
nur um die einzelne Investition sondern
es geht um das was dahinter steckt weil
China eben nicht nur in Hamburg
hafenanteile hat sondern auch in den
Niederlanden und in Portugal und in
Griechenland und in vielen anderen
europäischen großen Häfen und damit
Zugang hat zu Informationen und ein
Netzwerk baut mit dem es waren Ströme
ein Stück weit kontrollieren kann besser
kontrollieren kann als jeder andere
europäische Reederei und das ist kein
Zufall dass China das macht es gibt zwei
große staatliche bäckerei-konzerne die
hier gleichermaßen jetzt Kunde als auch
Besitzer
teilbesitzer von Hafen Terminals sind
und das muss man sich in Zukunft viel
genauer anschauen ob das wirklich das
Geld was der der Hafen jetzt bekommt an
Investition den Wert ist nach meiner
Einschätzung ist es das nicht wert
ja zu diesem Thema habe ich auch eine
Frage aus unserer Community an sie hier
fragt jemand auf Youtube nach Huawei und
Co muss sich der Westen eventuell auf
einen Handymarkt komplett ohne
chinesische Firmen einstellen
das wäre tatsächlich möglich und gerade
der
Handymarkt oder konkreter der
Telekommunikations der der netzmarkt ist
einer der Bereiche wo wir das
tatsächlich auch ohne chinesische
Technologie können weil es nämlich in
Europa mit Ericsson und Nokia
Unternehmen gibt die tatsächlich genauso
gute 5g Netze bauen können und das ist
zum Teil teurer China kann das günstige
anbieten auch aufgrund von hohen
staatlichen Subventionen die bei uns in
dieser Form gar nicht erlaubt wären aber
das ist ein Bereich wo wir wirklich
eigene Technologie hätten Länder wie
Japan die würden nie auf die Idee kommen
chinesische Telekom Konzerne dort die
Netze bauen zu lassen funktioniert prima
für die
und auch hier wieder das heißt nicht
dass wir überall die Kappeln müssen das
Netz ist dabei viel kritischer als das
Handy als einzelnes Produkt aber wir
müssen uns eben in vielen Bereichen die
total harmlos erstmal der herkommen
genau anschauen ob wir damit nicht eben
uns Abhängigkeiten schaffen die dann
hinterher politisiert werden
sie sagen gerade Japan würde nie auf
diese Idee kommen man denkt da natürlich
auch sofort an die USA die ihre
Infrastruktur nicht in Kooperation oder
ein Teilen mit chinesischer
Unterstützung aufstellen wie würden Sie
denn die chinesische Stadt die USA
Strategie zu China mit der aktuellen
Strategie Deutschlands zu China
vergleichen
die USA sind China natürlich als großen
weltpolitischen Rivalen die USA haben
den Anspruch in jeder Hinsicht die
globale Nummer eins zu sein eben nicht
nur wirtschaftlich sondern auch
militärisch da werden die Amerikaner von
den Chinesen ganz offen herausgefordert
und dieser großmächtige Konflikt
zwischen den USA und China der betrifft
auch den ganzen Rest der Welt wir in
Europa konkret in Deutschland haben mit
dem militärischen Komponente gar nicht
so ein großes Problem wir können damit
leben dass China auch militärisch
mächtiger wird für uns ist es wichtig
global Spielregeln zu haben die für die
Wirtschaft gelten die für die Politik
gelten die Märkte offen halten die
Stabilität schaffen die Korrespondentin
hat auch gerade angesprochen wie viel
Warenverkehr rund um Taiwan stattfindet
wenn es dort zu einem Konflikt gibt
kommt
riesiger militärischer Konflikt sein das
kann schon eine teilweise Blockade oder
größere Manöver sein dann merken wir das
sofort hier weil dann Lieferungen von
Produkten aus Asien nicht mehr zu uns
kommen und uns noch mal zu sagen das
sind dann eben Dinge die bei uns Preise
in die Höhe treiben oder Lieferengpässe
schaffen
das meinte Miriam von wie sie schon
gesagt haben ne dieser China Taiwan
Konflikt sollte der sich zuspitzen das
eine große geopolitische Katastrophe
können Sie uns zum Schluss noch mal ganz
konkret sagen was ist der Einfluss auf
die deutsche Wirtschaft und vielleicht
auch ein Einfluss den jeder oder jeder
einzelne von uns dann direkt zu spüren
bekommen würde
also den einen habe ich gerade gesagt
das ist die Menge der
Containerschiffe die durch die Straße
von Taiwan aber auch durch
Südchinesische Meer und überhaupt in der
ganzen Region unterwegs sind die Waren
von Asien zu uns bringen und wir haben
kürzlich gesehen was für ein riesigen
Einfluss das hat wenn allein der
Suezkanal für ein paar Tage verstopft
ist das würden wir dann noch in viel
viel größerem Ausmaßen sehen zweiter
Aspekt wo man es daran festmachen kann
ist dass
teilweise natürlich ein entscheidender
Rolle spielt in der globalen Halbleiter
in der Chip und Produktion und wenn dort
Zulieferungen nicht kommen dann stehen
weltweit Produktion still weil ohne
bestimmte Chip Zulieferungen geht es
dort einfach nicht weiter und wenn sich
einmal vor Augen führen in wie vielen
Produkten heute eben Halbleiter drin
sind dann ist ein bewusst dass jede
disruption der Zulieferketten dort
unmittelbar was damit zu tun hat was wir
bei uns erhalten können oder wie wird
darüber nachdenken müssen uns
Alternativen aufzubauen aber
Alternativen aufzubauen ist eben immer
mit sehr großem Aufwand und sehr großen
Kosten verbunden
vielen Dank dass Sie meine Fragen und
die Fragen der Community beantwortet
haben vielen Dank
vielen Dank
ja ihr seht das ist ein wahnsinnig
komplexes Thema ihr könnt euch aber
sicher sein wir bleiben weiterhin für
euch dran wie sich diese Strategie
entwickelt wie die Wirtschaft darauf
reagieren wird wie auch die Politik
weiter darauf reagieren wird ihr könnt
es hier Auschecken bei ZDF heute live
ich wünsche euch einen schönen Abend und
vielen Dank für eure fragen Kommentare
[Musik]